c'est ainsi qu'un massage ya bien
longtemps la lune et les shadoks sutter
la terre cahin caha temps pour aller mon
principe vers l'infini et même plus loin
si c'était possible il quitter sans
aucun regret une serre qui était loi de
leur avoir procuré un temps de crise
acosta d'esprit et la terre les dix
partis de la même façon le train
interstellaire shadoks comportait
première non un module en forme de cosmo
autobus ou les shadoks à grosse tête
faisait des calculs derrière venaient la
lune qui servait des tâches propulseur
par le truchement du succès attendu de
vin blanc briques du professeur tad au
cou
tout cela est parfait et aux mots de
rien le drain shadox et l'orbité
terrestre pour se placer sur la
trajectoire de voyage de forme
approximativement shadow koïta à ce
moment là comme vous le savez il est
d'usagé en astronautique de se
débarrasser de laitages propulseurs qui
pratiquement ne sert plus à rien les
shadoks à grosse tête sont parfaitement
au courant de tout ça d'après lui la
route tous les tâches propulseur
évidemment la chine protège
il n'allait tout de même pas les laisser
en plan perdu là ont plein mines
l'espace c'était pas humain la technique
c'est la technique dévoile a condamné à
mourir ici a tout au moins à y rester
jusqu'à la fin des essais triste fin
mais depuis le temps qu'il faisait
pompes et les autres après tout hein
ils n'ont que ce qu'ils méritent et
notre histoire de ce point de vue là ce
n'est pas tellement il moral que ça